in the previous episode
are you prepared to give your life to
save your son that
exactly ah [ __ ] it we're gonna die one
way or another
we found the Origami Killer everyone's
happy end of story you didn't find [ __ ]
this trip back Norman Norman I'm
disappointed Miller's name is here
somewhere in this theater I just have to
find it find it before it's too late go
watch there we go I've seen this before
somewhere yes we have
yes we have for Larry's promotion do you
remember brother in the beginning the
Killer is a cop
tell me yeah why don't you just tell him
to know who killed my son
listen when I'm done I'll tell you
everything I know I promise all right
oh well what are you gonna do
I don't know they just don't
all right so here it is
the Killer is finally revealed
Scott Shadow me
how's it going breath welcome to the
final episode
of heavy rain we just found out who the
killer was Madison already knows who the
killer was if you remember at the
psychic Hospital
and he's about to visit here it's her
apartment [ __ ] I can't talk come on
Maddie moo
show your girly skills that's not really
a girly skill but you know
I don't know
oh
this is the first time I ever do this
not Amber but in this game
oh hello I lost your touch girl girl I'm
a Lost Girl
what is that
the origami Killer's apartment
it must be something that'll tell me
where Sean Mars is can she goes in
without a gun huh all right she got to
be fast he could come back any time
ah let's check the garbage
that's where the smell of burning comes
from evidence Going Up In Smoke
God damn it huh what do we got here did
you delete all of it
what is that what is this
uh
yeah we know he's a cop
come on that's useless
we gotta go through it room by room but
there's bound to be some kind of Clue
sure that's where you find all the
colors totally good oh in the fridge
all right maybe here in the drawer
I don't remember honestly
he's a cop
so handsome to be a cop and less fat
probably knew exactly how an
investigation would be carried out
pops uniform
always trust a cop
that's why children went with him he was
dressed as a cop
does actually make a little sense
that sounds like my type of Locker
so he grew the orchids
he has a secret room just to grow
orchids
he really likes oh [ __ ] it needs a
Pizza how about
about
John
and Craig
how about
no origami It's gotta be origami
yeah yeah origami
what
Max
got it oh relax the name John gave to
his paper dogs when he was a child
what the hell is that
an address it's got to be rich on Mars
is
hurry there's no time to lose all right
we did everyone literally is on to the
killer right now I don't know it's
exciting ah
so you found my little secret I didn't
see your porn I swear it's really weird
but all those children killed just to
find a father capable of saving his son
shut up you don't understand
there's one child left there might still
be time to save him let him go do what
your father couldn't do
come on Scott
[ __ ] you Scott I thought you were cool
you were always really fat
all right don't panic just stay calm and
think
and then let's break some [ __ ]
ah
stupid walls
ah all right yeah that worked
good job man nice bye
Maddie moo come here
well that was [ __ ] easy
she could have waited a little bit is
that smoke
that burned fast as [ __ ]
don't die now Maddie moo
all right charged
how's that auto come on Bros I can do it
come out
why did she always in the ass he's not
Nyan Cat
am I moving I am moving oh
I love this game it's when you have to
like
come on move this chair ah
poor little thing
get away from Milan oh I saw something
it's way too hot
I'll kill myself if I jump we gotta find
something else
uh don't jump I'm not gonna jump there
what lamb came back to kill me
all right
we gotta find another room
this doesn't exactly look at that
those windows oh there's a gas [ __ ]
tank whoa ow
oh [ __ ] stop
I don't have time for you now fire
stop crying don't worry
it's a gas tank it's gonna explode it's
gonna be awesome everyone's gonna love
you
all right this has better [ __ ] work
it's way too high oh come on I'll kill
myself if I jump
I gotta find something else
don't jump
come on Madison we went through so much
together
do it wow
now what I what I'm so confused
no why not
oh it's R2 and r2d to [ __ ] me no
all right don't worry
dump it
so which one of these doors
well I guess the other one it's not open
Madison take the oh
take the other one
or give up you can do that you can give
up and die
or take that door
why not that door
lemons were [ __ ]
okay there we go
come on this place is gonna blow
Madison it's time to move
get out of my way
[ __ ] your coffee [ __ ]
foreign
Madison what are you planning right now
because I don't really like it
whoa Madison
oh yeah that window was open
run manimo
laughs
cool girls don't look at explosion
they blow things up and they walk away
come on get to the address
it's gonna be awesome I don't think I
ever had everyone onto the killer before
all right so call Ethan I know where
Sean is I've got to tell Ethan well
Ethan already knows Maddie
is that one of those phones for old
people
I do believe so
let's go there go there and kiss him
yeah that's right
take it
good old motorbike yeah that's right
take your time Adam
all right
the final scene is coming here I think
not sure
Ling Ling you forgot your bling bling
what why are we playing as you
I don't want to play with you
you look like tin tin or some [ __ ] like
that
are you
clever dad what oh no we're playing as
the as the sun
really
ah
dad oh we found it
we didn't even have to kill him we did
we shouldn't have drink in that thing
though [ __ ] why did I do that well
you're living your land apparently
replay no I'm not gonna
save your son man
please be alive
there it is
it's open to rain water
I've been looking for a long
long time either
looking for a father that would be able
to do why
sacrifice himself
in order to save his son
oh I searched
searched
and then
I remembered you
I was in the news
he was there
all those voters
just to find a father capable of saving
his son a father yes do you have any
idea how it feels to be a worthless
nothing in your father's eyes
believe me
I'd suffered
judges my victims
I finished her damn trials Now give me
back my son
he's there
all you have to do is open that great
he tracks me
[ __ ]
Jaden
get what
there's a [ __ ] lock there in case you
haven't seen it
oh [ __ ] what do we do I'll get you out
of there Sean
maybe we can grab one of these gotta
open this goddamn Creek gotta find
something fast
oh [ __ ]
well where
yeah don't run why would you run
where do I go this perfect
come on man
whoa he actually did it [ __ ]
come on man
come on I want to see what the ending is
of course we're gonna save him
I hope he's not dead that would be not
very good
he has nothing in his nose all right now
he plays Jayden
oh
so he owns this Factory how [ __ ] rich
is he what
well I didn't want to explain where all
his money went to
I guess he wanted to keep a low profile
[ __ ] is Origami Killer oh that's one to
the boss
dad
I played
oh [ __ ] that doesn't help
come on down [ __ ] you
Jaden the master of dutching
Jaden Dodges everything
all right don't throw [ __ ] that's not
cool
can he not throw everything he can find
at me oh [ __ ]
foreign
suspect is likely to be armed and
dangerous all Personnel are ordered to
shoot to kill I repeat shoot to kill Ash
are the snipers in position yes snipers
they're ready on your command perfect
he won't get away this time we'll gun
him down as soon as he shows his face
hey what is he gonna do there
what are you doing
Lieutenant my name is Madison Page I'm a
journalist I have proof that Ethan Mars
is innocent he's not the Origami Killer
what is a journalist doing here I
thought I told everybody to keep their
mouth shut
you're out of here I don't want her
getting in the way okay lieutenant
all right come on you're about to make a
terrible mistake Lieutenant Ethan Mars
is innocent I can prove it
yeah and she knows who the Killer is too
right to the boss
[ __ ] man come on come on Daddy you can
do this I believe in you
oh oh
it's not so funny now is it [ __ ] you
[ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah
come on man
it's a lot of these things going on
don't help me son please
free
gotta breathe
come on man
they got night out
come on
no
don't leave me
images
come on
he's dead
I don't remember that
ah
[ __ ] you game
make me all sad and [ __ ] oh
God damn it oh
I thought you were gone he was faking it
just for drama God damn it
I knew you would come and save me you're
like I shed too
what's going on that
he's gonna die now sure listen
you are the best thing that's ever
happened to me in my life
I want you to know that whatever happens
I love you more than anything in the
world
um
I I'm Not Dead
I took the poison an hour ago
and I'm Not Dead
I said yesterday
I trust me I'm not surprised as you are
I don't remember
holy [ __ ]
Ash get her out of my face Mars didn't
[ __ ] you go to Pikachu [ __ ] he's
innocent
what am I doing exactly I have no idea
whoa
what is she doing
what is that crap
hold your fire I repeat and hold your
fire
what's going on the cops are outside
they have the building surrounded
they'll shoot you if you go outside
I'll go out alone I'll talk to them I'll
explain you'll be dead before you can
open your mouth
look we'll all go out together with our
hands in the air and they can't possibly
shoot us
I have the evidence that produce your
innocence
no one cares about it Sean anymore
listen
I'm sorry I didn't trust you
I was only thinking about Sean and I
thought
that's okay
the only thing that matters is that you
saved your son
come on Jaden
you got oh [ __ ]
man
so unfair
Jaden takes so much crap
head shy Jason that was awesome save me
what should we do right
oh [ __ ] I get
help him
I actually killed him in my other
playthrough oh you son of a [ __ ] you
killed Jaden I'll kill you
[ __ ] you if Jayden dies because of this
I'll I'll
why did I trust him
why am I so good-hearted son of a [ __ ]
what
that's gonna sting tomorrow
what about him what about him Jayden
don't fall down Jayden don't fall thank
you
God damn it
that is awesome
we did it Bros
I think we got the best ending going I
hope so I mean everything looks really
good
that does not look that good though well
I guess it depends
I'll just sun and a little bit
foreign
I did it
we can go on forget her
well I got a lot of achievements going
there was General understanding when the
police announced that they had found
Sean Mars alive more than four days
after his disappearance Mars had been
imprisoned in a well by The Man known as
the Origami Killer well who is it the
successful resolution of this case was
made possible only by The Bravery of
Ethan Mars wait he was Killers he
believed at one point to be the Killer
and you no doubt Jude who is great
courage and tenacity that he succeeded
in foiling the plans
the police commissioner presented him
with an official apology today our main
headline today it is reported that the
police have identified the man thought
to be the Origami Killer Scott Shelby 48
is a former police Lieutenant who
claimed to be a private eye hired by the
families of The Killers victims
a massive police operation but further
details have not yet been released to
the public
it's an app we'll get to see each ending
of each character pretty much
I I actually really really like the
ending where that's the bad ending so I
might actually show that
right after this one because I really
like it I don't know maybe you'll have
to play through the game to actually
enjoy this is the ending let's just say
a friend of a friend let me jump in line
if we like it it's ours
then they live together huh
well it's pretty similar to her
apartment
what is he doing hey Dad I think I found
my room where well
what do you think
perfect Ethan
we'll be able to forget what happened
will lead a normal life
and one day it'll all just seem like a
bad dream
we've earned the right to be happy now
Ethan
all three of us
what the hell did she do
is
and I I think we'll see Jade yeah
Jaden's ending
it's actually a
what
Our Guest today is on the cover of
today's World magazine this week and has
been hailed by the whole nation as a new
hero for our times all right
astonishingly he almost single-handedly
ended the Sinister series of killings by
The Man known as the Origami Killer and
save the life of young Sean Mars his
determination courage and intelligence
have won our admiration Norman Jaden
all right cool
so he's all right then I know there's
another ending where he goes crazy and
starts like hallucinating and [ __ ] so
this is a lot better I guess unless he's
doing it right now [ __ ]
don't hallucinate Jaden
no throw that down the party pooper
you might want to reconsider that
foreign
good job Jayden I'm proud of you man so
what happens at FBI then
maybe this is what I was talking about
what is he doing
there's no
uh this is what I was talking about I
guess you get these ending regardless
honestly
and there's yeah
oh okay oh okay
I get it no they're still here [ __ ]
God damn it
uh-oh don't shoot me bro
I didn't do it
I enjoyed it
I really like that ending I don't know
that's about another one where he sees
like elephants and [ __ ] I don't remember
oh well
this is one but I'm really curious what
happens poor girl man
we fell in love with
her son's killer
killed my son Scott
who are you thinking about that when you
held me in your arms
I don't know why you did all this
nothing can justify it anyway
nothing but contempt
foreign
I feel really bad for her
she went through so much everyone went
through so much
went along I guess
I want to see them again I'm a father
too bam
all right press
that was Heavy Rain uh
if I turn this thing up
uh I'm so glad I replayed this I
I I'm remembered by why I love this game
so much
uh it really really is one of those
games that you'll you really remember
and you really appreciate obviously I
don't remember all parts of it which is
actually a good thing because I that
left me surprised in a lot of parts
anyway all right Perez as you can see
I'm trying out something different you
have four different choices on what you
want to see next
um I know a lot of you are like oh
parody you should play whatever you want
to play It's okay but you know what I I
want you to Bros to enjoy when I'm
playing two that that gives me joy as
well so for me to get a good idea on
what you want to see and what you don't
want to see
um basically you vote by clicking uh the
link on what you want to see next and
I'll
determine which one has most demand for
and I'll I'll go from there so I wanted
to go through them really quick the
first one is indigo prophecy also called
Fahrenheit it's the same maker as heavy
rain Quantic dream and the graphics are
a bit outdated it's a bit old but it
shouldn't be a problem honestly the
reason why I chose not to play this
before heavy rain was because
um it seems a little bit messy a bit
messy to comment it on and I hear some
parts are really rushed about the game
but I I still heard great things about
it should still be a good story
the second game is siren blood curse
which is a game that I stopped let's
playing and the only reason why I
actually stopped less playing is was
because I had to sit on the floor to
actually play a record with my
PlayStation which was really annoying
and I I didn't like that and now I have
a better setup so it's not really a
problem for me obviously because Heavy
Rain is on the PlayStation but any
anyway
there was a lot of people that were sad
when I stopped let's saying that so I
want to hear that people actually care
or not if you want me to play it or not
anymore uh the third option is Heavy
Rain DLC I don't know how many DLC I
hope at least two but I'm not sure that
was released for heavy rain and they
were actually really good I heard good
things about them I just don't know if
ebros are interested in seeing any
further things about the Heavy Rain
thing or not so let me know what you
think about that last but not least is
limbo it's a game that I totally want to
play it's kind of a puzzle game very
beautiful very artsy I love the style of
the game
um I totally want to play it but I don't
know if there's demand enough of you
bros for one meter plate so those are
the four options
um you can click on more than one if you
want to see more than just one of these
things uh so yeah I just want to get
good idea on what you both want to see
thank you for watching this let's play
of heavy rain I really really enjoyed it
I was almost cracking cracking up when
Sean was dying there God damn it uh but
yeah thanks for all the support Bros and
uh stay awesome you know I love you
I'm totally professing by the way are
you breakfasting all right cool